in this morning's high on money what
house hunters should expect this home
buying season
median home prices are up especially for
existing homes
which have soared nearly 16 percent
since february 2020
but inventory is way down dropping
almost 30 percent from a year ago
and mortgage rates while near historic
lows have inched up to just over 3
percent
for a 30-year fixed loan cbs news
business analyst jill schlesinger joins
us now
jill good morning so if new and existing
home sales
were down last month why are prices
still so high
well they were down last month and i
know that that was a little bit of a
shock but
year over year meaning we wind the clock
but to
february of 2020 activities up by eight
or nine percent depending whether it's
an existing or a new home
and the real critical issue that has
plagued the housing market is
a lack of supply as you said down nearly
30 percent for existing homes
some economists believe that's even
understating the problem
so when you have a ton of people coming
into the market
a limited supply prices are indeed
higher and you know all that limited
supply anthony also exacerbated by the
fact that some
boomers didn't want to list their homes
in the middle of a pandemic
and when you look to new homes
unfortunately the price
in new homes is also rising not only
because of a lack of supply
but the actual cost of the materials
whether it's crude oil that's used in
paint it could be copper used in the
lines
so all put together prices are indeed
higher
and a lot higher for many would-be
buyers a lot of people relocated because
of the pandemic
how what's the long-term impact going to
be on the housing market of that do you
think
well i think that it really depends you
know a lot of people
were at home whether they were working
at home because their
companies put them home or because they
were home with their kids
they looked around they wanted space now
here we are
at hopefully the end of the pandemic
with
kids going back to school now the
question really becomes
what will happen and i think that the
move that we've seen
is from the big cities to sprawling
suburbs
now we're looking at smaller cities it
could be austin
charlotte nashville and some of these
even
smaller cities are providing cash
incentives to get you to move
there are websites that will in hook up
buyers with these
incentives and fascinating places like
baltimore right outside dc
you can get five thousand dollars
towards the purchase of a new home there
how do you know what you can afford in
this market jill
it's so boring when i say this but it's
run the numbers
and you know i'm sorry to say that
because it's still the case look
there's principle there's interest
there's your homeowners insurance
there's your taxes
don't forget every home owner will tell
you don't forget to add in the
maintenance one to three percent
of that purchase price has to go in
there and you've got to make sure
that you account for these factors and
make sure you're not going to preclude
yourself from achieving other financial
goals maybe that's paying down your
student loan debt
maybe actually it could be that you
would need to be saving more for
retirement so weigh those factors
well good advice jill schlesinger thank
you very much